- [Instructor] We are
asked to find the value
of this indefinite integral.
And some of you, in attempting
this, might try to say,
all right, is the numerator
here the derivative
or a constant multiple of the
derivative of the denominator?
In which case, u-substitution might apply,
but it's not the case here.
So what do we do?
And my hint to you would be
partial fraction decomposition,
which might invoke some memories
from a precalculus class
or maybe from an algebra 2 class,
but it's a technique to break
up this rational expression
into the sum of two rational expressions.
And a good hint there is the fact that
this denominator here is factorable
into these two expressions.
So what we're gonna try to do
with partial fraction
decomposition is say,
can we express x-5 over (2x-3)(x-1),
can we express it as a sum
of two rational expressions,
where the denominator of the
first rational expression
is 2x-3,
and the denominator of the
second rational expression
is x-1, and I don't have to
put parentheses there, is x-1.
Now we don't know the numerators.
As you might have learned before,
and I encourage you,
if this the first time
you're ever seeing partial
fraction decomposition,
look that up on Khan Academy.
We have many videos on it.
But the general principle here
is that your numerator is
gonna be one degree less
than your denominator.
So our denominators here are first degree,
so our numerator's gonna be
zero degree, or just constants.
So it's gonna be some
unknown constant data.
Let's call that A.
And some unknown constant B.
And our goal is to solve for A and B.
And this is all a review.
This isn't really calculus.
This is more precalculus now, or algebra.
How do we solve for A and B?
Well, let's add them
as if we're just adding two fractions
with unlike denominators.
So we wanna have a common denominator.
So what we wanna do
is multiply this first rational expression
by x-1 in the numerator
and the denominator.
So you could call this A(x-1)
over (2x-3)(x-1).
And then for this second
rational expression,
we'd multiply the numerator
and the denominator
by 2x-3.
So (2x-3)B
over (2x-3)(x-1).
And now, since I have the same
denominator, I can add them.
And the goal is when I add 'em,
and I think about the
numerator, I will try to say,
well how do the A's and B's line up
to what we have already, right over here?
So this is going to be
equal to, same denominator,
so the denominator's (2x-3)(x-1),
and then in the numerators,
actually, let me do it over here.
This is the same thing as
Ax-A, just distributing the A,
and if I distribute the B here,
this is the same thing as 2Bx-3B.
And so if we add the numerators,
we can add the x terms,
Ax+2Bx, so we could call that (A+2B)x.
And then if we add these
constant terms, -A, -3B.
And since we have a minus right over here,
I'm gonna try to pattern match,
so I'm gonna have minus,
and I'll write that as -(A+3B).
If you distribute this negative sign,
then you're gonna get -A and -3B.
So these are equivalent.
And now we can see the pattern.
We say, all right, our
denominators are now the same,
so this thing in our numerator has to be
the same thing as x-5.
So whatever our coefficient here is on x,
that's gotta be equal to 1,
that's the coefficient on x.
And this thing that we're subtracting,
that's gotta be equal to 5.
And we're gonna set up a system
of two equations with two
unknowns to solve for A and B.
So we know that A+, so
let me write that down,
we know that A+2B needs to be equal to 1.
And we know that A+3B, or A+3B,
is going to be equal to 5.
And so now, to solve for A and B,
well, we could do that by elimination.
So let's see, what if we
multiply this top equation by -1.
So that'd be -A, -2B, -1,
and now we add them together.
The whole point was to cancel out the A's,
so we're left with -2B+3B,
that's just going to be B,
is equal to 4,
and then we can substitute
back in to solve for A.
So let's say right over
here, we know that,
we know that A+3x4,
so that's gonna be 12,
I'm using this equation right over here,
is going to be equal to 5.
Subtract 12 from both sides,
you get A is equal to -7.
So just like that, we can
rewrite this entire integral.
We can say this is going to be equal to
the indefinite integral
of, open parentheses,
A over 2x-3.
We now know that A is -7,
so it's -7 over 2x-3,
and then we're going have +B, B is 4,
so, +4 over x-1,
over x-1, and close parentheses, dx.
Now if you are so inspired,
I encourage you to pause the video
and try to run with it from this point,
because we have seen the
techniques to solve integrals
like this before, but
I'll do it step by step.
This is going to be the same thing as,
well actually let me just,
so this is going to be the same thing as
the integral of, so 2x-3.
I could write the -7 here,
but I'm gonna take the
constant out of the integral.
So I'll put a -7 here.
And to help us solve this,
and this could be a 1,
but to help us solve this,
it would be nice if we had a 2 here.
Why is that?
Because 2 is the derivative of 2x-3,
and so then we can do our u-substitution,
which we have, sometimes,
gotten practiced doing
a little bit in our head.
And so if we want this to be a 2,
we can't just multiply by 2.
We've also gotta divide by 2.
And I can do that outside,
'cause that's just a constant
dx+, well the derivative of x-1 is 1,
so we just want a 1 up in the numerator.
So we can take the 4 out of the integral.
4 times the integral of 1 over x-1, dx.
So this is going to be equal to,
we just have our constant out front, -7/2,
and since we have this
thing in the denominator,
and we have its derivative,
we can really just think
about this as integrating
with respect to this
thing in the denominator.
You can sometimes view u-substitution,
which I'm not explicitly going to do here,
as the reverse chain rule.
The antiderivative of 1
over x is the natural log
of the absolute value of x,
but here, this is going,
the antiderivative of this
is going to be the natural log
of the absolute value of 2x-3.
And then for this part, it's gonna be +4,
times the antiderivative here
is the natural log of the
absolute value of x-1.
Once again, I can do that,
'cause the derivative of x-1 is just 1.
And of course, since we're
taking an indefinite integral,
we do not want to forget our +C.
And we're done.